Video is sponsored by Qiskit,
more details later in the video.
From the first idea of a quantum computer in 1980
to today there has been huge growth in the quantum
computing industry, especially in the last 10
years. With dozens of companies and startups
spending hundreds of millions of dollars in a
race to build the world’s best quantum computers.
For most of us it’s quite hard to get our
heads around the world of quantum computing,
and a lot of information about it glosses over
important details. This video aims to clear all
this up and if you watch the whole thing you’ll
have a very good overview of all the different
kinds of quantum computing, how they work, and
why so many people are investing in the quantum
computing industry. This is the map of quantum
computing. Quantum computers solve problems in
a different way to the computers we are familiar
with, which, from now on I’ll be referring to as
classical computers. Quantum computers have
certain advantages over normal computers for
certain problems which comes from their ability
to be in a huge number of states at the same time
whereas classical computers can only be in
one state at a time. To understand this,
and to understand how quantum computers work you
need to understand three things: superposition,
entanglement and interference. The building
blocks of a classical computer are called bits,
and the building blocks of a quantum computer are
called quantum bits, or qubits for short, and they
work in fundamentally different ways. A classical
bit is kind of like a switch that can either be
a 0 or a 1 which you are probably already
familiar with as binary or binary information.
When we measure a bit we just get back the state
that it’s currently in, but we’ll see this isn’t
true of qubits. A qubit is more complicated. For
a useful visualisation you can think of them as
an arrow pointing in 3D space. If they point
up they are in the 0 state and if they point
down they are in the 1 state, just like a
classical bit, but they also have the option to
be in a thing called a superposition state which
is when the arrow points in any other direction.
This superposition state is a combination state of
0 and 1. Now, when you measure a qubit the output
it gives will still end up being either a 0 or a
1, but which one you get depends on a probability
which is set by the direction of the arrow. If the
arrow is pointing more upwards you are more likely
to get back a 0 than a 1, and if it is pointing
downwards you are more likely to get a 1 than a 0,
and if it is exactly on the equator
you’ll get either state with a 50%
probability. So that’s the effect of superposition
explained, now we’ll move on to entanglement.
In a classical computer the bits
are independent from each other.
The state of one bit is not influenced
by the state of any of the other bits.
But in quantum computers the qubits can be
entangled with each other which means they
become part of one large quantum state together.
For an example let’s look at two qubits which are
each in different superposition states, but aren’t
entangled yet. You can see the probabilities next
to them, and these probabilities are
currently independent of each other.
But when we entangle them, we have to throw away
those independent probabilities and calculate a
probability distribution of all of the possible
states we can get out. Either 00, 01, 10, or 11.
The important point here is because the qubits
are entangled, if you change the direction of
the arrow on one qubit, it changes the probability
distribution for the whole system, so the qubits
are no longer independent of each other, they are
all part of the same large state. And this is true
no matter how many qubits you have. You’ll also
note that for one qubit you have a probability
distribution over 2 states. For two qubits you
have a probability distribution over 4 states.
For three qubits you have a distribution over
8 states, and this keeps on doubling each time
you add another qubit. In general, a quantum
computer of n qubits can be in a combination of
2^n states. So I’d say this is the core difference
between classical computers and quantum computers.
Classical computers can be in any state you want,
but can only be in one state at a time, whereas
quantum computers can be in a superposition
of all of those states at the same time. But
you may wonder how being in this superposition
state can be useful in a computer. Well for that
we need the final component: interference.
To explain the effect of interference we
need to go back and look at my picture of
a qubit technically called a Bloch sphere.
A qubit doesn’t actually look like this,
this is just a really nice way of visualising
the state of a qubit. In reality the state of
a qubit is described by a more abstract entity
known as a quantum wavefuncion. Wavefunctions
are the fundamental mathematical description
of everything in quantum mechanics which I’ve
described in more detail in a previous video.
When you have many qubits entangled together all
of their wavefunctions are added together into an
overall wavefunction describing the state
of the quantum computer. This adding
together of wavefunctions is the interference
because, just like with say ripples of water,
when we add waves together they can constructively
interfere and add together to make a bigger wave,
or destructively interfere to cancel each
other out. The overall wavefunction of the
quantum computer is what sets the different
probabilities of the different states,
and by changing the states of different qubits
we can change the probabilities that different
states will come out when we measure the quantum
computer. Remember that even though the quantum
computer can be in a superposition of millions
of states at the same time, when we measure it,
we only get a single state out. So when you are
using a quantum computer to solve a computation
problem you need to use constructive interference
to increase the probability of the correct answer,
and use destructive interference to decrease
the probabilities of the incorrect answers
so that when you measure it the correct answer
will come out. Now how you do this is the realm
of quantum algorithms, and the whole motivation
behind quantum computing is that, theoretically,
there are a bunch of problems that you can solve
on a quantum computer that are thought to be
intractable on classical computers. Let’s take a
look at them. There are many quantum algorithms,
too many to describe in this video, so we’ll
just focus on the most famous and historically
important: Shor’s algorithm. If you have two large
numbers and you multiply them together there is
a very fast, efficient, classical algorithm for
finding the answer. However, if you start with the
answer and ask, what are the original numbers that
multiply together to make this number? It is a lot
more difficult. This is known as factorization,
and these numbers are called factors,
and the reason finding them is so hard is because
the search space of possible factors is so large.
And there is no efficient classical algorithm
for finding the factors of large numbers.
For this reason we use this mathematical property
for internet encryption: secure websites,
emails and bank accounts. If you know these
factors you can easily decrypt the information,
but if you don’t you’d need to find them first
which is intractable on the world’s most powerful
computers. Which is why in 1994, when Peter
Shor published a fast quantum algorithm that can
efficiently find the factors of large integers,
it caused quite the stir. This is the moment
that a lot of people started to take the idea
of quantum computing seriously because it was
the first application to a real world problem with
potentially huge real world security implications.
But when I say a ‘fast’ quantum algorithm,
how fast, and how much faster than a classical
computer would it be? To answer these questions
we need to take a little detour into the world
of quantum complexity theory. Quantum
complexity theory is a subfield of the
world of computational complexity theory which
deals with the categorisation of algorithms,
sorting them into bins according to how well they
run on computers. The categorisation is based on
how much harder it is to solve the problem as the
problem gets larger. Here any problem inside the P
box is easy to solve with a classical computer,
but anything outside it means we don’t have
efficient classical algorithms to solve them and
factoring large numbers is one of these. But there
is a box, BQP which is efficient for a quantum
computer, but not a classical computer. And these
are the problems that quantum computers will be
better than classical computers at solving. As I
said, complexity theory looks at how difficult it
is to solve a problem as the problem gets larger.
So if you factorize a number with 8 digits, then
you add another digit on, how much harder is
it to factor the new number compared to the old
one? Is it twice as hard? Exponentially harder?
And what is the trend as you add more and more
digits? This is called its complexity or scaling,
and for factorisation it is exponential. Anything
with the N in the exponent is exponentially hard.
These exponential problems are the problems that
really screw you over as the problems get bigger,
and in the world of computer science you can win
respect and renown if you find a better algorithm
to solve these hardest problems. One example of
this was Shor’s algorithm which took advantage
of the special features of quantum computers
to create an algorithm that could solve
integer factorisation with a scaling much
better than the best classical algorithm.
The best classical algorithm is exponential,
whereas Shor’s algorithm is polynomial which
is a huge deal in the world of complexity theory
and computer science in general because it turns
an intractable problem into a problem that can
be solved. Solved, that is, if you have a working
quantum computer, which is what people are working
on building. But you don’t need to worry about the
security of your bank account yet because today’s
quantum computers are not able to run Shor’s
algorithm on large numbers yet. I’ve estimated
they would need about a million qubits to do so,
but so far the most advanced universal quantum
computers have around 100. Also, people are
working on what’s known as post-quantum encryption
schemes which don’t use integer factorization,
and another technology from the world of quantum
physics can help here too, a cryptographic scheme
known as quantum cryptography. So that
was a look at just one quantum algorithm,
but there are many more each with different levels
of speedup. Another notable example is Grover’s
algorithm which can search unstructured lists of
data faster than the best classical algorithm.
But I should be careful here to make sure I
don’t mischaracterize classical computers.
They are very versatile devices, and there
is nothing to say that someone may find a
very clever classical algorithm that could solve
the hardest problems like integer factorization
more efficiently. People think it is
very unlikely, but it is not ruled out.
Also, there are problems that we can prove are
impossible to solve on classical computers,
called non-computable problems, like the halting
problem, but these are also impossible to solve
on a quantum computer. So computationally
classical computers and quantum computers
are equivalent to each other, the differences
all come from the algorithms that they can run.
You can even simulate a quantum computer on a
classical computer and vice versa. But simulating
a quantum computer on a classical computer gets
exponentially harder to do the more qubits you
are trying to simulate. This is because classical
computers struggle to simulate quantum systems,
but because quantum computers are already quantum
systems, they don’t have this problem which
brings me to my favourite application of quantum
computers: quantum simulation. Quantum simulation
is simulating things like chemical reactions
or how electrons behave in different materials
with a computer. Here quantum computers also have
an exponential speedup over classical computers
because classical computers really struggle to
simulate quantum systems. Now I’ve made a whole
other video about quantum simulation which you
can watch here, but basically simulating quantum
systems with as few as 30 particles is difficult
even on the world’s most powerful supercomputers.
We also can’t do this on quantum computers yet,
but as they mature a main goal is to simulate
larger and larger quantum systems. These include
areas like the behaviour of exotic materials at
low temperatures like understanding what makes
some materials superconduct, or study important
chemical reactions to improve their efficiency,
one example aims to produce fertiliser in a way
that emits way less carbon dioxide as fertiliser
production contributes to around 2% of global
carbon emissions. Other potential applications
of quantum simulation include, improving solar
panels, improving batteries, developing new
drugs, chemicals or materials for aerospace.
In general quantum simulation would mean that we
would be able to rapidly prototype many different
materials inside a quantum computer and test all
their physical parameters, instead of having to
physically make them and test them in a lab which
is a much more laborious and expensive process.
This could be a lot faster and save a huge amount
of time and money. It is worth reiterating that
these are all potential applications of quantum
computers, because we don’t have any quantum
computers that can solve real world problems
better than our normal computers yet. But these
are the kinds of problems quantum computers would
be well suited to. Other applications outside of
quantum simulation are optimization problems,
machine learning and A.I. Financial modelling,
weather forecasting and climate change, which
I’ll be honest I don’t really understand how
this would work, and finally cybersecurity, which
I think just boils down to shor’s algorithm, which
I already described. Now we need to be a little
careful about the potential of hype here, as a lot
of the claims of what quantum computers will be
good for come from people who are actively raising
money to build them and so it makes sense for them
to piggyback on topical subjects in their pitches.
But my take on it is that historically, when a new
technology has come along, the people of the time
aren’t the best at being able to tell what it’s
going to be used for. For example the people who
invented the first computers never dreamed of the
internet, and all of the things on it. And this is
likely to be the same for quantum computers.
But for me the application that I can really
understand the value of is quantum simulation
which is why I've focused on it in this video.
Anyway, so far I’ve described how quantum
computers work and what problems they can solve.
But most of what I’ve talked about so far is
theoretical. For the rest of the video I want
to focus on reality. How are people actually
building quantum computers, and what can they
actually do? Now it’s worth mentioning here
that some physicists are sceptical that it will
ever be possible to build quantum computers at
the scale needed to solve real world problems,
but people working on all of the following
certainly don’t agree. Now quantum computing
is often portrayed as if it is a single thing. But
inside the world of quantum computers there are
a large range of approaches to turning different
kinds of quantum systems into quantum computers,
and there are two layers of nuance I need to talk
about. First of all are the models of quantum
computing: the overall approach to manipulating a
collection of qubits and then there’s the physical
implementations: the actual quantum objects you
build your qubits from, like a superconducting
loop, or individual atoms or photons. We’ll
start with the models of quantum computing.
It is interesting that there are different
models of quantum computing, because this is
not something we see with classical computers.
Practically all the computers we use today
work in the same way, they have a bunch of bits
holding the binary information of ones and zeros,
and we can do operations on these bits
using logical gates which are basically
simple operations that flip a bit, called a
NOT gate, or compare bits like giving you a 1
if two bits are both zero, and a 0 if they
are anything else this is called a NOR gate.
Interestingly you can build a full general
purpose computer from just bits and NOR gates.
In quantum computing there is a similar
model called gate model, or circuit model
which is the most popular and most
understood model of quantum computing.
In the circuit model you have your collection of
qubits which are entangled with each other, and
then you have a bunch of gates which can perform
operations on small numbers of these qubits
which change the states of the qubits without
measuring them. A quantum algorithm is built
from a sequence of gates applied to the qubits in
a certain order, and then a measurement at the end
when you get the final state, which hopefully is
the answer to the problem you are trying to solve.
Simplistically you can think of these gates as
operations on the qubits that rotate the arrows
to point in different directions. And these
operations change the probability of the final
state of each qubit when it is finally measured.
Now there’s more to this which I don’t have time
to explain here, but if you want to learn more
about them and do some quantum computing yourself
I highly recommend the educational
website and YouTube channel called Qiskit.
They are kindly sponsoring this video, and
honestly they are the best resource for people who
want to learn more about quantum computing and get
some actual hands-on experience. Basically Qiskit
is a software framework funded by IBM to make it
easier for people to get into the world of quantum
computing. Everything there is free to access and
the code is all open source, there is an online
text book which teaches you all the basics, so if
you don’t have a quantum physics background that
is no problem at all, you can learn everything
you need there. Their Qiskit YouTube channel is
also full of excellent tutorials and lectures,
I’ll link to all of this below. And in terms of
quantum algorithms you can run through examples
of quantum circuits using their online tools.
And if you want to run your own quantum
programs you can download their open-source
SDK and run them on IBM hardware, either on
classical simulators of quantum computers, or
on actual real world quantum computers, for free.
And the SDK is not only tied to IBM hardware. I
used to work at another quantum computing company
called D-Wave, and there is an interface to their
computers in the SDK as well if you want to learn
about their approach called quantum annealing and
many other companies are available too. Personally
I’ve been using their website to learn gate model
quantum computing deeper because my background is
in quantum annealing and I’m super happy that this
educational resource exists, and is free to use so
please check that out if you want to dig deeper.
Finally I just want to state that I’ve had
complete editorial control over the content
of this video and my goal is always to be as
objective as I can, I just want to make sure you
know that Qiskit is funded by IBM who are building
quantum computers, and I used to work for D-Wave
who are making other quantum computers, just for
transparency so you know everyone’s backgrounds.
Right, back to the models of quantum computing
we’ve already looked at the circuit model,
but closely related to it is measurement based or
one-way quantum computing which involves setting
up an initial entangled state, and then measuring
qubits one by one during the computation,
and mathematically this has been shown
to be equivalent to the circuit model.
Now let’s look at the models I’m most familiar
with: adiabatic quantum computing and quantum
annealing. Adiabatic quantum computing works
in a very different way to the circuit model.
In adiabatic quantum computing you are taking
advantage of one of the fundamental behaviours
in physics, the fact that every system in physics
always moves towards the minimum energy state.
This is a very general principle, and adiabatic
quantum computing takes advantage of this by
posing the problems you want solved in such
a way so that the minimum energy state of the
quantum system is the answer to the problem.
You can picture this as an energy landscape,
where each point on the landscape is one of the
potential outputs of the computer. In adiabatic
quantum computing you start off with a flat
landscape, and gradually introduce the energy
landscape of your problem where the answer to
your problem is the lowest position on the map.
If you do this slowly enough, the quantum
computer will always stay in the lowest
energy state so that when you measure it you
are most likely to get the correct answer.
I should mention that I’m having to simplify
things a bit here to make it easier to understand,
but it gives you the right picture of what is
going on. In reality I would need to talk about
Hamiltonian’s and eigenstates but that’s beyond
the scope of this video. Even though adiabatic
quantum computing is so different to the circuit
model, they have been shown to be mathematically
equivalent, and problems can be mapped from one
to the other. And they are both something called
a universal quantum computing scheme which means
that theoretically they can simulate any quantum
system. Strongly related to adiabatic quantum
computing is quantum annealing which is not a
universal quantum computing scheme, but works on
the same principle as adiabatic quantum computing
with the system finding the minimum energy
state of an energy landscape that you give it.
The reason it is not universal is because it
doesn’t have the full degrees of freedom to
represent any quantum state, but even with this
limitation it can still be used to solve certain
energy landscape problems like optimization
problems and simulate certain quantum systems,
and example is spin glasses which are grids
of magnetic fields connected to each other.
And quantum annealing is a stepping stone to
building a universal adiabatic quantum computer.
The last model we are going to look at is called
topological quantum computing which is currently
the most theoretical model of quantum computing
because it builds its qubits from an entity in
physics called a Majorana zero-mode quasi-particle
which is a type of non-abelian anyon.
Which is a bit of a mouthful and obviously
quite confusing but the important term here is
quasi-particle. Quasi-particles aren’t fundamental
particles like atoms, electrons or photons,
quasi-particles are created from the collected
behaviour of many particles together, and end up
having particle-like properties despite not being
actually real. The clearest example of this is an
electron hole: if you have a grid of electrons
with a gap in the middle, as the electrons fill
in the gap it looks like this hole moves in
the opposite direction. This hole isn’t real,
it’s just a hole, but you can treat it like
a particle with particle-like properties.
In condensed matter physics there are a large
range of different kinds of quasi-particle and
a Majorana zero-mode quasti-particle is an entity
that has been theoretically predicted, but there
is still significant debate over whether they’ve
actually been experimentally observed or not.
Now the reason why physicists are excited about
this model is because these quasi-particles are
predicted to be a lot more stable than other
qubits because they are made from parts which
are physically separated from each other. This
is good because the main source of failure in
a quantum computer is noise, which comes from
rogue forms of energy creeping into the quantum
computer making the qubits drift away from
where they should be and causing errors.
But these quasi-particles are special because they
are protected from the noise by an energy gap.
Basically what this means is it takes a certain
energy to bring the parts of the Majorana particle
back together, so any perturbations of noise which
have a lower energy than that energy gap is not
felt by the quasi-particle. This might have been
a bit confusing, but that’s okay I’m still getting
my head around them too, but that was just the
best boiled down description I could come up with.
Okay so that rounds up the different models of
quantum computation, but how do you actually build
them? There are a huge range of different physical
implementations of quantum computers because
there are so many different quantum systems
that you could potentially build them from.
The requirements to build a qubit is actually
fairly simple: all you need is a two state quantum
system when one state will represent 0 and the
other will represent 1. The most obvious example
of this is the spin of a particle: the spin can
be up or down, but as we shall see there are many
properties of particles we can use. In fact, there
are too many for me to list them all, so I’m just
going to focus on the implementations that are the
most widely used and have been the most successful
so far. But no matter what the approach is, they
all face a similar set of obstacles which we need
to take a look at first. In general it’s really
hard to control quantum systems because if you
have got any slight interaction with the outside
world the information starts leaking away. This
is called decoherence. You want your qubits to be
entangled with each other, but don’t want them to
be entangled with anything else. But the trouble
is, your qubits will be made of physical stuff
and you will need other physical stuff
nearby to control and measure them,
and your qubits are dumb they’ll
entangle with anything they can. So,
you need to design your qubits very carefully to
protect them from entangling with the environment.
Then you need to shield your qubits from
any kind of noise: things like cosmic rays,
or radiation from things like phone calls, or
heat energy or any other kind of rogue particle.
Unfortunately some amount of decoherence and
noise is inevitable in any physical system,
and is impossible to eliminate completely. And it
gets worse the more qubits you have entangled with
each other. This is the big open question still
hanging over the whole field of quantum computing:
is it ever possible to make a working quantum
computer with a large number of qubits, or will
decoherence and noise ruin everything? There
are strong opinions on both sides, and I guess
we won’t know for sure until we actually build
them. One plan to deal with decoherence and noise
is quantum error correction. This is an error
correction scheme to make fault-tolerant quantum
computers by using many entangled qubits together
to represent one noise free qubit. How many
you need depends on how good the qubits are, but
estimates are in the range of 100 to 1000 physical
qubits to make one fault-tolerant qubit. Which
is a lot of qubits. And this brings us to another
major obstacle: scalability. For each qubit you
need to have a bunch of wires to manipulate and
measure it. For a small number of qubits this
is all manageable, but as the number of qubits
increases the amount of extra stuff you need
increases linearly, which is a massive engineering
problem. So any quantum computer design needs to
somehow be able to entangle all of the qubits,
and then control and measure them in a scalable
way. So those are all the problems with building a
real quantum computer, let’s take a look at the
different approaches scientists are pursuing.
Superconducting quantum computers are currently
the most popular approach. A superconducting qubit
is made from superconducting wires with a break
in the superconductor called a josephson junction.
The most popular type of superconducting
qubit is called a transmon where the two
level system is encoded in pairs of the
electric charge moving across the junction,
specifically the frequency at which charges
oscillate back and forth across the junction.
But there have been other designs that
use the magnetic flux in a loop of wire,
or the phase across a wire as a two level
system known as flux qubits or phase qubits.
Physicists have also looked at ways of making
qubits out of fundamental entities like atoms, or
electrons or photons. Next are quantum dot quantum
computers or silicon spin quantum computers.
Here I’m using quantum dot quantum computers
to collect a range of qubit designs built from
semiconductors, things like silicon. Here the
qubits are made from electrons or even groups
of electrons and the two level system is encoded
into the spin or charge of the electrons. On the
chip there’s a small area where the electron
is restricted to is called a quantum dot,
and operations on the qubits are performed through
voltages on the chip, or microwaves or magnetic
fields. As well as silicon, people have also
used other semiconducting materials like gallium
arsenide, silicon carbide and also diamond amongst
others, which all have different properties.
Next we have linear optical quantum computing.
Optical quantum computers use photons of light
as the qubits and they operate on these
qubits using optical elements like mirrors,
waveplates and interferometers. At scale this has
been accomplished by printing these elements into
integrated photonics chips. The two level system
in an optical quantum computer can have different
designs, either a superposition of different
paths a single photon takes through the chip,
or a superposition of different numbers of photons
present in a path. And these can be manipulated by
applying a voltage to a path. Now onto trapped
ion quantum computers which use charged atoms
as qubits. These atoms are ionised, having a
missing electron, which makes them electrically
charged and means they can be levitated and
moved about with electromagnetic fields.
Here the two level state that encodes the qubit
are two specific energy levels of the atom which
can be manipulated or measured with microwaves
or laser beams. Next we have colour centre or
nitrogen vacancy quantum computers which are
similar to trapped ion quantum computers in
that the qubits are made from atoms, but instead
of being trapped in an electromagnetic field,
they are embedded in a gap of the material like
nitrogen embedded in diamond or silicon carbide.
There are a few different ways to make
these, but typically the qubits are
the nuclear spins of the embedded atoms and
they are entangled together with electrons.
The final approach is called neutral atoms
in optical lattices. In this approach the
qubits are atoms, and the design uses cold atom
physics capturing neutral atoms like caesium
into an optical lattice which is a crisscrossed
arrangement of laser beams, which form energy
wells shaped kind of like an egg box. These atoms
are cooled down with lasers to a few millionths of
a kelvin and there are a number of ways to encode
the two level system the qubit is built from:
either the hyperfine energy level of the atom
or excited states and they can also make use of
Rydberg atoms. And the atoms can be controlled
and entangled with each other with lasers.
They can also be used as quantum simulators
as well as quantum computers. In fact a 10,000
atom quantum simulator has been made, but this
doesn’t look like a universal quantum computer.
These are the main approaches I’m going to cover
in this video, but it is not an exhaustive list,
some other qubit designs include:
Electron-on-helium qubit,
Cavity quantum electrodynamics, Magnetic Molecule,
Molecular Spins, NMR quantum computers. But these
have not been built at the same scale as the
other approaches I mentioned in more detail.
So that was the map of quantum computing and
that should give you an excellent overview of the
field. As you can see, there are many different
approaches to building a quantum computer,
and what is so interesting is that it’s not yet
clear which approach will win out in the long run.
Now one thing I haven’t covered in this video are
the companies and startups and which approach they
are using, along with their current best quantum
computers, and their roadmaps into the future.
But this is what I’ll look at in my next video
so keep your eyes peeled for that. You don’t
need to subscribe or anything, but check back in a
couple of weeks if you think you’d be interested.
And like all my maps this map of quantum
computing is available to buy at my store
dosmaps dot com, or to download as a digital
image for educational purposes links to all
of that in the description below. Quick note
though, due to logistics we can only get the
map of quantum computing to you after the
holidays, but everything else in my store
is ready to go. We also have many educational
posters and a range of engaging kids books about
science called Professor Astro Cat, so if you
are looking for some gifts that will help your
loved ones learn about science, check that out.
Dosmaps dot com. Finally, a massive thank you to
all my patreon supporters. As you can
probably tell I put a huge amount of work
into these map videos and the support on patreon
is invaluable. Thank you. And I’ll see you soon!